hello everyone are you guys doing hope
you guys are having a wonderful day
today we are here with a little money
making method um it does involve a
little bit of risk however I mean pretty
much with any good money making method
it's either risky or you kind of have to
merge stuff so it's not something you
can do all the time this however is
something you can do all the time
that's a sexy-ass putt that dude's got
there and yeah it's pretty much I don't
know it's something you can do all the
time you do need money to start doing it
I mean literally you could do it with
like a male just you do need some base
money
however it's definitely worth it so as
far as requirements go you're just going
to need to have done the little mini
quests that involves the same rock I
think you need broom mystery it's done
and then you need to do a mini quest
with the same rock mage that is over
here so give me one second I'm gonna
look at the name with a [__] the mini
quest I think it's literally just called
yeah mages a rock it's literally all
it's called so yeah so you need to have
done both of those both things literally
take like I mean room mr. E's quest
takes like 5 10 minutes same with the
mini quest it's nothing too hard so
basically what you're gonna want to do
from there is go to your bank and grab
what I will be grabbing right now so as
far as armor go it's just something to
protect yourself you're gonna be a right
up here to the north right about here
this is where you enter the room
crafting little area I don't know what
it's called the abyss there we go the
abyss so there are people that come to
pk here personally I'm just gonna just
bring like one item I would recommend
you can't bring three if you want that
are pretty good for defense but
realistically you're going to be with a
lot of food and a decent amount of money
but you're gonna have a lot of food and
armor and you're going to be at like
level 4 wildy so especially if your love
level you shouldn't have to worry too
much about it so basically what I'm
going for here just some mage defenses a
little bit of melee defense because you
know I mean if you're gonna if you're
gonna come out here with a lot of money
you probably want something that can
actually defend you even the slightest
and I'm gonna bring out this HP cape
because it looks pretty [__] nice I
would admit and yeah so we're gonna go
out there with that and yeah so give me
one second now for your inventory
personally I'm gonna take
about five mil and you can take out more
or less depending on how long you want
to be out there or how much money you
have the more money you have obviously
the more money you will make out there
so I feel like that's pretty obvious but
I figure I'll tell that to people for
you know in case they were wondering so
I'm then going to bring seven brews a
quick tap teleport away even though you
could have a glory if you wanted to and
then just some combo food just to make
sure you can't get SPECT out and sharks
so with this you should be good to go
protect all the stuff you got if you
want you can reorganize the inventory so
everything's a little closer like you
could have it all set up so like I don't
know realistically you won't be dying
out here so you should be pretty good to
go as you can see with my defenses right
now we do have a good amount of mage
defense that's a [__] lie what the
hell did I do I'm guessing the DFS just
destroyed that you do need a little bit
of defense out here oh that's my attack
bonus okay
I'm dumb there we go 107 all right so
basically what you're gonna wanna do you
see these skeletons these things are
going to be annoying if you are uh Negra
but what you're gonna want to do is just
run follow this river and you will see
this mage of samurai trade the major
same Rock and as you can see there are
death runes 500 and every world and they
are worth 180 coins so as you can see
here they're actually worth 295 which
means if you bought 10 right now you'd
literally make like 1.2 K problem is
every time you buy some the price goes
up a little bit personally I would buy
about 200-250 in every world that you go
into I'm going to be doing that for
about 15 minutes half an hour here in a
second the one thing I will be doing
though and this is what is annoying
about these things is there are
skeletons all around this now you can
kind of like work this and like try to
get the mage like block it off like this
like I just did and then talk to the
mage and then she'll stay in one spot or
he I don't know I don't want to assume a
gender that's a beard I'm gonna say he
um but yeah so you can kind of trap them
that's what I did yesterday so you can
kind of trap him if you want personally
I'm just going to go ahead and get di
growed so I can show you guys the max GP
per hour that you can have anyways guys
as you can see too many login attempts
the best way to do this is if you have
an alt you can you know run two accounts
and then just you know alternating
alternate yeah but just to run two
accounts at once you like five minutes
of just world happen world happen
constant um the one thing I noticed
though if you do not have if you are a
growed this will not happen so you don't
have to worry about if you're on a
growed you will have to worry about this
I'm gonna end it off here I did about
I'd like to say about 13 to 14 minutes
of it and stuff so we're gonna go back
in the game and you guys are about to
see this [__] alright so here we go big
reveal let me get to the edge of the
building real quick I didn't see any
other peek errors other than that one
dick as I was trying to get me in my
world that I was gonna I got uh neg Road
on so you should be pretty good
however thirteen will say thirteen
minutes because I think that's about
right we were able to get five point
eight K death ruins and it cost us 1.3
mil so we're gonna go ahead and price
check these so we're gonna throw all
these in there and all of this it as you
can see in 13 minutes I was able to make
336 K so that's pretty [__] good I
would say 336 K in 13 minutes I'll do a
little bit of math on this so you guys
have some ideas alright so as far as GP
per hour this then averages out to one
point six mil however you can make more
than this the one thing that I noticed
that I wasn't making money on was
because this was a pretty prime time of
the day it's like 8 p.m. ish my time so
I mean it may not be perfectly prime
time but last time I did this to test it
out I made I think it was around 280 K
in 10 minutes so I was at that point
averaging like 1.8 millage so I know you
can definitely get up to that on a groat
I believe you could get it up to 2 mil
if you have two accounts running it
would be and say it'd be it'd be 3 to 4
mil an hour so yeah it I mean I would
imagine I'm not entirely sure I know out
of the 13 minutes I was logged on I did
spend about 3 or 4 minutes waiting to
hop world so for what we got there if
you do this at like a at like a regular
base time I guess if you do this at a
regular time then you can probably
expect to get about like 1.5 mil ish
now that this video is out it may not be
as good but it will be good in the
future [__] me but it will be good in
the future so just remember this method
for whenever you need to get money holy
[__] dudes [__] sketchy [__] anyways
it will be good in the future and I'm
gonna say for this video sake you can
probably get one point seven at one
point eight mil to accounts right and
you'll get a ton of money but hope this
uh hope this video is helpful for you
guys hope you guys learned a little bit
of something if you guys did feel free
to like like up the video show a little
bit support against everything I can
approve Punk comment about it down below
and yeah you want to see more of my
money making videos as soon as they come
out so you can be the first one to do
the money making method video before it
gets ruined by other people because
that's naturally how it goes and then
after like two weeks it's fine
I feel free to hit that sub button
nonetheless that'll be it for me too